Đóng đau hoang thông thị dời thì tụi thống trộng mạnh khi như của gia Trung Đông đồng đồng loạt đống cửa
Họ thẳng chế không phần, cho một cạnh thẳng thẳng giữa Mỹ-serail và Yvang lau thang
Các không phận quan trọng như Yvang Yvang Israel cà ta U.A. Khoa, Bà Rang Và Siri, Biện Hường,
khiến hàng in trên bây phải quyết, quáng hoặc đổi lúc trình.
Tại trường tâm, trung chuyển lống đại đu bay đông 20 đối đối bây giờ, và bởi vì khi nhận tình trạng giá đoạn nghiêm trọng
Chúng khi nhau hàng thông có thể tạm dự khai thác, quốc tránh bây qua khu bực dù giò,
việc mất cả hàng là máy chính lượng, bộ máy bây bây vòng xa hơn,
kéo dài hàng trình thêm nhiều dơ, và làm chí vị vận hàng tăng đáng kể.
Theo dưới phần tích, viên hướng tuyên bây không chỉ làm tiêu hàng như liệu,
mà còn gây áp lực lịch chính khai thác thẳng gầu,
với hàng hướng đến vận tạng khách vàng quá.
Gián như liệu tăng củy cơ giám đoạn chủ cùng mứng,
khiến hàng hàng không bốn mở chỉ phục hồi sau đại dịch,
ở đối mặt với nguyên cơ thì tại lớm nếu tình trạng làm cửa phần phận tiếp tục kéo dài.